I think that when I first started
teaching that teaching is considered
kind of the great shame of of jobs in
Japan
[Music]
and then I became a twitch stream and I
realized no there's lower so I I am okay
but no it got him yeah it's true um but
no teaching is an interesting profession
right of course in most societies it's
highly respected and then you take one
look at someone like me and you realize
maybe not but the thing is is I think a
lot of people want to come to Japan and
they need an opportunity to do so yeah
and imagine
for example
you have no marketable skills or a
theater degree or really selling
yourself
but if you did have those things but you
have a bachelor's well then you've got
an opportunity to come to be a teacher
that's just Asia right yeah it's it's
just like it was the same thing in
Thailand where you could like you could
be the most under like all you need is a
bachelor's and that you can get like any
job you wanted and it could be and it
could be any battery yeah yeah well
trust me I know like in America I had a
theater degree right which is about it's
really good for waiting tables like
you're a greater it's listening well and
that's um but when you come to Japan and
you do teach I think the expat Community
or the other people who are in Japan
look you know they look down upon it
pretty heavily okay so that's one thing
I've wanted to ask straight up all right
because like I think there's a lot of
people who watch Trash taste and just
like Japan content in General right so
obviously they're like I want to be able
to go to Japan and when they go do their
research they realize okay the easiest
way is to become an English teacher in
Japan right like that's like the easiest
like Gateway method right but like I
think I think the general consensus of
like English teachers in Japan being
like as you put it like a shameful like
positional I guess history I don't I
don't I don't know I personally haven't
heard much about that so obviously you
have the experience of being in that
position none of us do yeah because why
do you think that is the case yeah
because uh I think we've met like a few
English teachers uh who have lived in
Japan but I think you have one of the
most interesting stories out of like
most out of like a lot of people we've
met and also
um you have like unlike a lot of people
we've brought on who has who have also
lived in Japan you've had the true expat
experience yeah for sure because you've
lived in Japan for how long now almost
uh 11 years or 12 years now well there's
something like I get it time loses
meaning yeah at a certain point it came
I came here right after the tohoku
earthquake of 2011. okay so about two
weeks that was a while ago but yeah two
a while ago it was a long time I think
though to answer your question about why
it's kind of disrespected and I do want
to be clear as much as I'm joking around
teaching can be a good profession here
yeah but the reason it's looked down
upon is we have to deconstruct like what
is a teacher and what is an English
teacher as a foreigner okay you're not
going to be you know reading Socrates
and explaining all of these cool
Shakespearean stories you are hired as
an Entertainer and or clown
this is you are the Court Jester and you
have to imagine you're you're not in a
college setting right right you're
teaching potentially kids who are
anywhere from the ages of zero all the
way through high school and if you're in
elementary school or junior high or
especially you know uh the kind of a
Kiowa special client like additional
education
get the big shoes and the red buttons
and be ready to sing some songs right
create some ridiculous lessons yeah to
make English fun and interactive okay so
I've I've uh you know I've heard about
being an English teacher in Japan and a
lot of like other Asian countries but
what is that actually entail what is
what responsibilities are on you and how
much do you have to plan how much it's
different based on what school and what
yeah yeah but what's like the typical
like step-by-step process as a full-time
is there a typical yeah let's go with
like the the three different scenarios I
think this will help kind of simplify it
sure let's start with the akaiwa okay
which uh a lot of people who did not get
into a school teach at an AK Iowa yeah
those are lessons that students come to
anywhere from like two years old up to
maybe Elementary School those are
usually planned out for you or you have
some sort of reference from a book that
some other expat wrote in 1977 and
you're like all right so we're gonna
teach colors today and it can be pretty
brutal like a normal lesson would be
something like this and this is why I
highly recommend you think very hard
about being a teacher you walk into the
classroom and there's about 13 kids
screaming crying sneezing puking
whatever [__] they're all [__]
they're all just playing with toys and
stuff you give them like five or six
minutes of toy time and this is the
hardest part A lot of the times this is
one of the first times that parents are
leaving their kids alone right so we
encourage them you tape up all the walls
and you say like just don't look through
the window and the doors don't be
visible because when the door shuts and
I start we need them to just be
distracted and not think where's my mom
and where right right yeah yeah that
never works
um like zero percent so you'll close the
door and you'll be like all right and
there's like songs you go like
God you're gonna give me PTSD you say
like I want to hear the song you're
lucky I can't stand up and do the full
performance baby clean up clean up
everybody everywhere clean up clean up
everybody do your share so you have to
put your butts to everyone do your [__]
yeah yeah everyone clean up your [__]
and stuff yeah that and then they
realize
my parents aren't here and the Water
Works begin it doesn't matter if it's
the first lesson or the 10th this is
something that you have to Grapple with
sure you bought your you know strawberry
Frappuccino with the three dollars that
you've made this year teaching and
you're just like I wish this was
alcoholic and then it's just you got to
do this every single day right five or
six days a week
um in perpetuity until you can escape
that job so this is obviously this is
yeah so this is obviously like targeted
towards you know like what average age I
would say anywhere from uh two all the
way until early middle school and the
middle schoolers are a bit the classes
are smaller it's a bit more personal you
can just say like what are you studying
in in school today let me help you so
those are kind of fun but anywhere in
the
oh man it is it is not but it can be
rewarding of course I'm saying that
because I had two or three good memories
but it is fun to see kids and you help
them learn like what does the color blue
look like in English all right so what
are the other you said that was the
first that's the first one then the next
is elementary school yeah so now you
have to start wearing the suit and you
have to start going to school and
sitting with the morning meetings with
the teachers and there's a lot of
differences from like America like as a
teacher you'd walk up to the the
principal and you'd say like
and he'd be like and then you'd go sit
down and then now you're now you're kind
of in this world where you have an
abundance of free time and you have no
idea how to spend it because you don't
have any money and you you can study
Japanese or you could you know look busy
on the computer but then the classes you
have anywhere from three to five a day
and it's like talking about the weather
or you go in there and tell them about
you know numb numbers or emotions and
then you repeat this for 65 years and
then uh but then the final one is you
get into Junior and High School junior
high school and high school yeah yeah
those are considered I would say the
best positions especially High School
finally the kids have an opportunity to
start explaining you know their
experiences and their they can actually
talk to you well let's not jump the gun
some can yes some some can talk to you
yeah but at least you can kind of
extract some
some information that's not you know
what train do you like it's Dr yellow
the shinkansen wow that's amazing or
your favorite color is blue okay and how
old are you I'm seven thank you you know
those are the basics but then in high
school you really get an opportunity
like you said to have conversations if
they choose to yeah if they choose to or
if they can or if they mostly if they
choose to yeah right yeah